les kilomètres à pied ça use surtout
avec les courses et ce n'est pas évident
qui dira le contraire
y'a pas bu ce jeudi à palacio dispose
d'un musée ou comme ça
la galère est une habitude pour les
usagers du réseau mozaik l'exercice du
droit de retrait pour les chauffeurs
aussi cette fois ci ce sont ceux de la
société so travaux mme l'un des co
traitant du réseau la vingtaine de
chauffeurs justifie le danger grave et
imminent par une longue liste de
dysfonctionnements qui va du pare-brise
fissuré à l'absence de climatisation et
aux deux questions qu'on ne travaille
nous sommes les seuls
je vais les techniciens une seule
experts ces véhicules là c'est nous qui
pouvons dire si les véhicules sont
confort des personnes selon un scénario
désormais tristement banale l'employeur
assure pour sa part que ces bus sont
conformes que l'eepad mineurs seront
réparés mais une reprise enfin on est à
un danger grave et imminent
je répète encore nos véhicules sont en
état de marche vous avez des usagers qui
souffrent j'ai même entendu sur des
zones qu'une petite dame a perdu son
emploi vous vous trouvez ça sérieux
depuis le 14 décembre
le droit de retrait a été levée par la
direction du travail en la personne de
madame martin et monsieur la croupe le
délégué du personnel à participent à la
réunion et l'a eu
il a bien entendu que le droit de
retrait est élevé et à ce jour ces
messieurs n'ont pas repris contacté
l'inspection du travail assure à ce
stade ne pas être officiellement au
courant des divergences entre employeurs
et employés
autant dire kevin n'a pas fini de
marcher